hello everyone and welcome to the third
game of the final match of the first
match
Daniel do oversee Cara Nakamura of
Dillon Doris a be rapid challenge Hikaru
won the first two games and now dubov
needs to win two games and demand to get
back into the match or the force
Armageddon so will we be able to do it
let's see what happens so now going back
from before he now chooses C for the
English opening is on the board we have
a five by hikaru Knight to c3 Knight of
6 knight of three in the knight to c6
the four Knights of the English and now
g3 preparing to fee and get to the light
square bishop not worrying about he
covers early d5 which Hikaru goes for as
a white allows it you could also block
it with e4 but a Nakamura plays this
line as well sorry do go plays this line
as well see captures Knight captures and
the bishop the g-tube just continuing
development night the b6 and castles
with Bishop to e7 and a3 now going for
b4 we have castles by Nakamura and just
before and it's very interesting this
game follows the game from 2017 Boris
Gelfand played against Edward that I get
from the one and I don't know if dubov
knows of this game but I kind of think
he does but okay Bishop to e6 and rook
the big one now preparing some b5 a for
later on with f6 strengthening the e5
pawn and now just b5 with nice to d4 and
ok you will not be able to capture and
then go for the phone here since after
this pawn captures your knight on c3
will be under attack so just III
captures and now there is one game in
the database where Queen captures was
played by white lost that game so after
that I don't think the Queen cactus is
no longer played so Bishop captures now
putting pressure on the b7 pawn and rook
to b8 Hikaru defends it and now d4
getting rid of that backwards pawn he
captures we have eight captures and the
Queen to d7 now also popular is Bishop
the east f7 as the rook to e1 is coming
and you don't want the bishop here to be
a target but he color decides for Queen
to d7 which defends the bishop and also
connects the rooks you can go some
Bishop to h3 moves or
like that so rook to e1 and now rook F
to e 8 you will still prepare bishop to
f7 with a 4 and now of course a bishop
to f7 with a 5 now kicking the knight
back and Knight to d5 now Knight
captures with Bishop characters on d5
and Bishop to f4 now preparing b6 as the
rook is still on b8 so like I said this
is exactly the same like in the game
gelfand Edward
we have rugby to c8 and now Bishop to g4
with a nice attack here so forcing a5
which Nakamura goes for and now in the
game we mentioned 2017 game front versus
Edward the Bishop to f3 was played but
here Du Bois first goes for a brush up
to h5 asking hey Carl do you want to
maybe mess up your pawn structure even
further with g6 or do you want to move
the rook
so here Hikaru decides on rook 88 and
only now thus do both go back Bishop to
f3 and now there's already a threat just
Bishop captures followed by rook
captures Bishop on e7 so Hikaru moves
the bishop back to f8 and now Bishop to
e5 just grabbing more space looking for
the right opportunity to execute beef b6
so Nakamura does it instead of white
we have b6 asking do you want to block
or do you do you want to trade here we
have captures C captures and now with
Bishop captures and d5 with Czech Queen
captures and Queen to a4 and now the
bishop pawn battery here really puts a
bind on blacks position it's very hard
for black to develop to make use of the
rooks and also the a7 zone is now under
attack
seeing ghosts obviously so rook the d7
just defending that pawn and the now
comes rogue beat the c1 challenging the
rook also if characters captures you
will be able to bring your own look up
to of the C file so rook cd8 and now
just work the c6 by do both grabbing
even more space and like I said this
really makes it hard for for black
developed but Nakamura is preparing
Bishop to d6 to finally get rid of this
Bishop but before doing that he pushes
f4 it's unclear why f4 instead of Bishop
to d6 but hehe door 1
characters and then you'll be able to
capture here or he wants to open up
White's position
dubov says okay I don't mind captures
now even though this diagonal is now
very dangerous it's very hard to get
those rooks into the attack if you could
get something like this it'd be great
however with the rook and c6 it's easier
said than done
so Nakamura goes for Bishop to b6 now
let's say if a trade happens here if you
get a rook somewhere over here then
maybe this will be a very dangerous
attack but Queen to c4 duel doesn't wait
for the attack he grabbed the pawn and
now he wants the trade Queens so the
queen is under attack we have Queen
captures and c4 route captures Bishop
captures captures and now rook the d4
going after the rook and the pond
nakamura would very much like to win
back his pawn however rook eat the c1
dubov just keeps the attention he wants
to get his King here and enjoy his extra
pawn and one very important thing is
that white is up a pawn but also White's
b-pawn is taking care of both of blacks
amb pawn so that's that will be that
will be very important if ever a king
and phone and game occurs so h5 by
Nakamura and now just King G to do both
starts bringing his King into the game
King h7 and now rook captures on d4 we
have rook captures and before end King
to f3 now so now the f4 pawn is nicely
defended we have looked a d5 putting
pressure on the b5 pawn but now just
east 6 Hikaru gives it up and the
problem is of course if you capture just
e7 there's no way to stop the past pawn
so King g6 you have to go after it and
now rook to e1 again just have that
phone I'm just gonna Queen my pawn and
there is no other move but to go back so
look the d8 by nakamura but now e 7
going after the pawn rook e8 blocking
but now rook the e5 putting pressure on
the h5 pawn so King f6 and now just King
to e4 and dubov says you have you can
have these 7 pawn my king is too active
now so rook captures an e7 there isn't a
better move and now we have characters
captures and just King to f5 and it was
in this position that he called Nakamura
resigned a game and dubov gets one point
so now it's due to one and dubov now
needs to win the fight
game well not the finally in Armageddon
will be the final game if uber wins but
he needs to win Game four with the black
pieces to force Armageddon so like I
said if a king and ponent game occurs
this one pawn guarding two two of these
guys is very important here if Nakamura
could get a passed pawn here he could
maybe have some counter play but here
it's just resigns for example king of
seven you're gonna go h4 and now after
g6 king g5 there are no more moves if
this you can give up one of your pawns
and now after let's say f4i you're just
gonna gobble up both of these points and
win the game easily sir after king of
five nothing more resigns and du Bois is
almost back in the match so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank shy cross arch for comment
Gabriel Luke blush Claridge and Richard
Wagner for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Lindo rest Abbey rabbit
challenge finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day